deuxième partie de la voie est libre
avec un gros plan aujourd'hui sur les
vins de bourgogne l'actualité le secteur
très important dans la région à
l'occasion de la saint vincent tournante
avec claude chevalier le président du
bivb bureau interprofessionnel des vins
de bourgogne
thierry gaudillère directeur de la revue
bourgogne aujourd'hui et guillaume
d'angerville président délégué de
l'association des climats de bourgogne
on avait terminé la partie précédente en
parlant de la sphère de la de la
flavescence dorée
il y à un autre élément qui a marqué
l'actualité c'est des chutes de grêle
extrêmement importante en bourgogne
il en a été beaucoup question dans les
médias
guillaume dangeard vite vous l'avez vécu
vous c'est toujours un moment difficile
c'est un moment horrible c'est un moment
horrible parce qu'on voit en dix minutes
le travail de toute une année qui est
détruit par quelque chose sur lequel on
a absolument aucun contrôle évidemment
donc c'est émotionnellement très dur
indépendamment du fait que
financièrement bien entendu c'est ça
peut être dramatique et c'est dur quand
s'est plusieurs fois au même endroit et
vous faites partie des villages alors le
village devenait a été effectivement
l'objet d'une série assez douloureuse
puisque 2012 2013 et 2014 ont toutes les
trois été très significativement grêle
et à vrai dire un petit peu moins en 14
caen 13 qui était lui-même un peu moins
que 12 à volnay un bonheur parce que
c'est pas partout pareil mais néanmois
c'est à ce degré là c'est très difficile
quand on fait sur trois ans
moins d'une année une récolte et
quelques à peu près à quoi sur trois ans
c'est quand même très difficile de tes
amis depuis dix ans non c'est pas les
seuls année depuis 10 ans et ça me donne
l'occasion de dire que on voit quand
même une accélération alors voilà le
chevalier pose des questions aussi mais
c'est très très bien mais est ce qu'on
se dit les choses sont pas normal c'est
de plus en plus souvent il se passe
quelque chose qu'on connaissait pas bien
sûr on peut pas dire autre chose c'est
évident quand quand vous cantonnement
nos vieux sage du village ce qu'ils en
pensent ils ont jamais vu ça donc il ya
quelque chose de nouveau et on parle de
réchauffement climatique moi je parle
plutôt de dérangement climatique je
pense qu'il ya on a l'impression qu'on
revient à des dérangements climatiques
type qui m'a tropicale presque parce que
on a plus de saison honnête et on a des
événements climatiques d'une violence
qu'on n'a jamais connu et ça ça s'est
accéléré énormément depuis 2000 qui est
moi je relis sa à la date de la tempête
de décembre 99 dans laquelle une partie
de la forêt au dessus de soirée colline
de volnay sur la montagne de volnay
comme on l'appelle une partie de ce bois
là a été décimée et n'a jamais été
replantés et je n'exclus pas je sais que
spéculer je n'exclus pas qu'ils aient
pas une relation entre cette ce premier
événement est la suite des choses parce
que on peut imaginer que les masses
d'air soit circulent différemment du
fait de l'absence du bois qui étaient là
avant
chevallier après la grêle les autorités
ont débarqué par la suite on a beaucoup
parlé de remettre et d'ailleurs ça a été
fait remettre en fonctionnement des
systèmes dont les anciens se rappelaient
qu'ils étaient des canons pour tirer
dans la grêle les anciens se rappellent
aussi qu'on les a utilisé et abandonné à
chaque fois ces systèmes là est ce que
finalement la seule solution c'est pas
l'assurance c'est la seule parce que
hamouda pour moi j'en parlais tout à
l'heure ensemble le
une des meilleures protections qu'il
peut y avoir même s'il n'était pas
efficace à 100 % mais l'été quand même
énormément tels avions anti grêle c'est
à dire que c'est la région qui décollait
quand il y avait le risque d'orage et
qui va lancer dur dur gens vraiment au
dessus du nuage
tous les autres systèmes fusée même même
les systèmes qui ont été mis en place
maintenant qui même s'ils sont
performants sont points à 100% parce
qu'on peut pas contrôler l'avion s'est
crashé le problème c'est que pour des
tas de raisons
c'est plus possible donc effectivement
aujourd'hui sur le plan national il en
train de se disputer d'un système
d'assurance qui sera un peu plus
performant a peut-être un peu moins
onéreux et puis plus dédommagement ma
vie plus de dédommagement que que ce qui
se passe en ce moment mais c'est celle
seul truc on est dans n'est
malheureusement que tu vas lui dire
comme moi on est dans un métier où on
sait qu'on est à la merci du temps on a
merci du soleil en à la merci de la
pluie on à la merci on sait que ça fait
quatre ou cinq années qu'on fait des
petites récoltes
c'est un problème écologique c'est pas
de chance c'est comme ça
la grêle c'est encore autre chose ce que
disait d'ions pardon ce que disait
guillaume leleu bois qui a peut-être
disparu aussi c'est peut-être une des
pistes alors on l'avait on l'avait
évoqué avec le préfet quand il était
venu juste après à paris s'est retrouvé
plongé dans la grêle d'une directement
on a pas on n'a pas de moyens efficaces
effectivement il ne après il ya
l'assurance qui fait qu'ils servent
seulement à ne pas mourir series
expérimentations faites avec des filets
antigrêle point de vue sur les se
résigne voir que cela pourra donner
on en parle beaucoup alors vous dans
l'activité de votre vue il ya la partie
dégustation qui a extrêmement importante
on va dire analyse critique des vins de
la région
ces phénomènes climatiques vous voulez
santé à travers ça aussi ces phénomènes
de graines ils ont une influence sur les
vins de bourgogne dernières années et
c'est une réponse de l rennes pas tant
que ça les phénomènes climatiques
oui en revanche oui il est évidemment
que
je suis bien d'accord sur le dérèglement
un plus que sur le réchauffement mais on
le sent quand même avec des dates de
vendanges ski qui sont quand même plus
précoce est sûr aussi forcément à terme
si cette évolution se continue une
évolution du style libre forcément avec
des vins certainement plus rond plus
plus plus evans soleil mais en même
temps ça le pinot noir sera toujours là
il y en a dans d'autres régions chaudes
ont également en bourgogne pourquoi pas
et et on remarque quand même que les
grands millésimes ceux qui sont portés
au pinacle 99
c'est un millésime plutôt chaud et donc
équipe les qui séduit il ya un autre
dossier dont on parlait ces derniers
mois et qui s'est accéléré depuis le
début d'année
c'est vos voisins c'est le beaujolais
pour que le grand public comprenne
il ya des rapports historiques depuis
longtemps entre bourgogne et beaujolais
mais il ya eu une accélération de
l'histoire ces derniers jours puisque
une partie du beaujolais le nord du
beaujolais qui produit ce qu'on appelle
les crus on va dire qu'elle est haut de
gamme du beaujolais a décidé de faire
sécession dans son interprofessions et
certains disent en beaujolais claude
chevalier qui a la main de la bourgogne
derrière tout ça pour récupérer une
partie du beaujolais c'est du sens
l'asse du fantasme reçu les rumeurs sont
toujours là c'est toujours facile
d'interpréter catastrophe qui se pose
quelque part on ya toujours des gens qui
ont du top 10 a donné tu je pense pas
que ça soit je suis pratiquement sûr
c'est pas la réalité
les viticulteurs du beaujolais n'ont pas
besoin d'être influencé pour prendre
certaines décisions comme n'importe quel
viticulteur dans le monde viticole
la seule chose c'est que je crois que
dans une région qui souffre depuis
plusieurs années parce qu'ils ont des
zébrures mois en réalité ce plusieurs
années
tout le monde cherche toutes les
solutions et il est bien évident mais je
vais le dire même si on leur reproche
d'être dans le beaujolais après mais il
est bien évident qu'aujourd'hui après
avoir une période folle avec les
beaujolais primeur qui a un peu étouffé
les crues il est bien évidemment
aujourd'hui que tout le monde sait que
c'est les crues qui vont remonter le
beaujolais donc il semble des fois un
petit peu méprisé ou ou pas entendu et
ça a causé une scission qui est pas
forcément la meilleure des choses qui
puissent à louis fabrice latour au vice
président de président-délégué votre
homologue qui représente le négoce a
parlé au début de votre mandat d' news
ce sera ça devrait être le mandat du
rapprochement avec le beaujolais
il avait dit ça alors c'est ça l'avenir
quand même un moment donné bourgogne et
beaujolais doivent créer quelque chose
ensemble
ou alors justement la petite guerre
civile qui s'y passe c'est que c'est pas
le meilleur moment et ce n'était pas le
meilleur moment mais la réalité c'est
qu'on en parle de aussi depuis plusieurs
années c'est pas un phénomène nouveau
le beaujolais à une partie de ses vins
qui sont déclarés en bourgogne à
replanter certaines parcelles qui sont
déclarés en bourgogne
bon on le disait tout à l'heure à lui
thierry guerrier a donné chiffre à nous
donner oui c'est le rapprochement des
vignobles
moi je n'ai pas d'avis sur le
rapprochement des interprofessions un
jeu pas vignerons là dessus moi je mais
par contre il dans les faits
techniquement il existe déjà il ya 2000
domaine en beaujolais il y en avait 4
milliards il ya une dizaine d'années
c'est à dire que la situation soit évité
il ya 2000 domaine aujourd'hui un
opérateur
il y en a 1000 qui déclare dans leur
déclaration de récolte produire du
bourgogne
alors ça c'est beaucoup quoi
concrètement pour ceux qui nous
regardent pas ce que fernand en
beaujolais rompt avec du chardonnay on
peut produire des vins de bourgogne du
vin blanc de bourgogne
le rhône est devenu le deuxième
producteur le deuxième département
producteurs de crémant de bourgogne
donc les liens sont existent sont et
équipe usée les débouchés commerciaux du
beaujolais sont pas souvent par des
opérateurs pour millions auxquels comme
moi je t'aime
bagnères viticulteurs l'audience me dit
on est le deuxième producteur de crémant
jeudi matin passerait moins fier parce
que j'aurais mieux produire du
beaujolais il vante le produire du
crémant c'est plus valorisant
mais ça c'est une réalité la bourgogne
le beaujolais la viticulture beaujolaise
faisait partie ce front a fait la grande
bourgogne que des parties où je parle
d'un viticulteur à ce que le négoce la
négoce fait partie de le négoce
beaujolais fait partie du négoce
bourguignon
ottawa une structure pour défendre leurs
intérêts mais la viticulture beaujolais
faisait partie de la bourgogne
donc dans le sein de la viticulture d'il
ya une quinzaine d'années ils sont
partis pour x raisons je pense que
aujourd'hui pour toutes les raisons
qu'on peut évoquer de de problèmes entre
les appellations régionales et puis ce
qui se produit dans le beaujolais etc
on ferait mieux de tout autour de la
même table plutôt que d'être dissocier
donc le fait qu'aujourd'hui le beau à
l'intérieur du beaujolais ya une
scission
ça va à l'encontre total de ce que tout
le monde voudrait céder y compris tous
les viticulteurs
je pense qu'il y avait une des
viticulteurs de boulot les compos
compris pourquoi je le sais parce qu'on
est à l'assemblée générale l'autre jour
il ya suffisamment de voix qui se sont
élevées pour dire on comprend pas il ya
quelqu'un qui a par licka même s'il a
peu répété dix fois c'est pas possible
c'est décès exactement ça c'est possible
quoi c'est nous reste deux minutes
produit par hbo sur le beaujolais
on parle de ces ce rapprochement ou pas
mais est-ce que ce que je voudrais dire
aussi celi vins du beaujolais qui sont
formidables
en termes de qualité et il mène en ce
moment un travail de caractérisation des
terroirs pour après identifié sa venue
dans notre proche les gens qui s'en vont
c'est d'estimer qu on met pas assez en
avant à l'intérieur de leur seconde
famille coin et voilà ça c'est et et une
qualité devon et on a deux suppléments
consacrés au beaujolais
on se régale c'est formidable nous a
déjà fait la gombe eaubonne vous puisque
bourgogne aujourd'hui à des numéros
consacrés au beaujolais
il reste une minute 45 démission c'est
quasiment fini à tout petit mot
puisqu'on est dans ce grand week end de
la saint vincent tournante
c'est un moment important guillaume
d'angerville
les producteurs vont aussi est un moment
c'est un moment très importante ça fait
partie de ça fait partie de ces
traditions de notre région qui sont tout
à fait remarquables
il faut pas faire et qu'il faut
absolument pas perdre qui font partie
des attributs de la valeur universelle
exceptionnelle de la bourgogne dans le
conte exécutant rattaché au climat mais
bien sûr on a fait on a fait il ya deux
ans je crois que c'était il ya deux ans
la race en temps dans des climats qui
était absolument formidable qui était
extrêmement fédératrice encore je tiens
à le dire c'est vraiment quelque chose
de fédérateur cette candidature doit
être fédératrice la slama sans tournante
c'est fédérateur et et ça fait partie de
ces attributs de la bourgogne
j'en reviens souvent disais au début à
propos des hospices gardons nos
traditions et c'est vrai que la fête de
la saint vincent tournante avec toutes
les sociétés sa maison qui se promène
avec leurs bannières avec leur simple
c'est un côté traditionnel convivial qui
j'allais dire n'est pratiquement qu'à la
bourgoisie on est un peu mais c'est une
grande part de réalité là dedans défaite
comme ça il y en a pas beaucoup dans le
monde du vin il y en a mais merci ça
pourrait être un joli mot de la fin
merci à tous les trois d'être venu
prendre le temps de faire comprendre à
nos téléspectateurs ce qu'est la réalité
du monde du vin c'est la fin de cette
émission ce week-end ne l'oublié pas
longues journées vigne et vin sur france
3 bourgogne avec cet après midi à 15
heures 20 une émission spéciale en
direct deux génies pour la saint-vincent
et dimanche millésime spéciale à 11h30
là encore émission c'est 80 cents pour
un week end
ça